the episode 4 preview of American Horror
Story is out and I'm here to decipher
what we might be in store for next
episode so if you haven't watched it yet
as always I've left a link in the
description below so come on back after
you've given it a look we are back at
perfect 10 aerobics in Los Angeles where
Montana is conducting a class if you
remember Montana's dream was always to
become a world-famous aerobics
competitor
notice how this scene has that film
grain look to it hinting that this is
something that happened in the past and
it looks like this is we're gonna see
the mammy res or Ram Tana I don't know
what do we call them guys origin story
and I mean who brings a knife to
aerobics class we have Margaret
confronting jingles asking him why he
came back but Margaret seems pretty
composed for meeting the man that
massacred her camp mates and almost
herself 14 years ago remember in episode
two Margaret has a gun in her desk here
so it'll be interesting whether she uses
it or not we get a better view of this
crazy trap Brooke narrowly dodges which
we saw in the season to come preview as
well and the eventual showdown between
Ramirez and jingles in Episode two
Margaret tossed Ramirez with taking care
of jingles and in return she would tell
him about the hitch-hiker he had killed
twice then there are two reused shots
both from episode one Brooke when she
went to get some first aid supplies and
Margaret in the rain it could just be
lazy editing or a hint that we'll be
revisiting previous events perhaps from
a different perspective Margaret is
still convinced to let the camp open
this is this woman is crazy and we get
this shot of what seems to be a camper
who gets her throat slit I've rotated
the image just so that we can get a
better look now the trailer is trying to
get you to believe this is chef birdy
since the next shot is of her cutting
some sandwiches with a knife but my
guess is that this is Margaret perhaps
back in 1970
you see birdy wears a ring on her left
hand and there's none here these nails
look too well manicured and the arms are
a bit thinner I did look back at all the
shots from the massacre and could not
find a camper who wore a rainbow type
shirt we also have mr. jingles cut
through a jelly sandwich with the same
knife that was used to cut the camper
but if we look at birdy she's not
wearing any gloves this could mean she
could be killed next episode or just
puts them on later we also have this
shot of Xavier with his
the jacket back on the last time we saw
Xavier he had given his jacket to Chet
after getting him out of that pit so him
having it back could mean that Chet
didn't make it or is somehow in a safer
place not to much to break down here but
I have a blast analyzing every frame and
I hope you do too please make sure to
give the video a like and subscribe with
the Belon and let me know your theories
in the comments below you can also reach
out and follow me on twitter at big
story why teeth until next time remember
daddy loves you very much